what I just said in the locker room to
the team is they got a make up in their
mind are they in love with this game or
they in like with
it cuz when you love something you give
to it
unconditionally you give everything you
got without a shadow of a doubt I am
truly 100% in love with this
thing and I just want people to match me
just match my passion match
my match my heart match my love match my
consistency just match my mannerism just
match every DN thing I give to this game
stuff like that make you get a second
guess and do you love this game or you
just like it you just like to play it
because it's fun and I get what he
saiding right there man you gotta love
this game to go out there and put your
body on on every day I love the game I
go there and D every chance I get
doesn't matter if I'm Rusty ready to go
I'm going out there to play give my best
I know a lot of players on the team love
the game but we got to show
more